hello and welcome everyone to EA play
20/20 we're happy that you're joining us
today
over the next 45 minutes or so we've got
so much for you including creative
innovative and really fun new games and
a lot of news to share but before we get
into the show I'd like to take just a
minute here I want to extend a heartfelt
thank you to first responders medical
staff and essential personnel this has
certainly been a challenging year from
natural disasters like the bush fires in
my home country to the devastating
covered 19 pandemic these brave heroes
are working to keep us safe and healthy
at every turn I also want to thank our
teams for their amazing dedication while
working from home what you've been able
to achieve is nothing short of
inspirational we're all so deeply
thankful to all of you our players even
when we've had to stay physically apart
billions of you are using games to come
together to play and do amazing things
for each other
you've shown why this is truly the
greatest form of entertainment on the
planet this is also a critical time for
the movement and racism and racial
injustice in this world black lives
matter and there is much to be done to
drive real and meaningful change a
couple of weeks ago we shared some
actions that Electronic Arts is taking
we will not rest on this it's a long
term commitment we're here for players
of every color background religion and
personal preference we will continue to
build strong representation in our games
and we are focused on making our
communities fun inclusive and positive
places to play we also have real work to
do to bring greater diversity into our
company and we are committed to doing
that work today we're here because of
the power of games games bring us
together they can make our lives better
they can teach us they can provide
escape and self-expression
and most of all games can be fun all of
us Electronic Arts believe in that and
it's why we're excited to get up every
morning to make great experiences for
all of you so thanks for being here with
us and now let's get into some games
[Music]
what's up everybody I'm Greg Miller and
welcome to EA play we had an incredible
show in LA planned for you
huge stage massive set up these giant
monitors I was gonna fly in in an x-wing
I was gonna land the x-wing on stage I
was gonna set off a bunch of fireworks
then what t-shirt came and bam shooting
out game consoles then Carol Baskins
some Tigers that last part was all me
then because of circumstances beyond our
control we had to come up with something
a little different instead of LA I'm in
my hometown of San Francisco but we
still the Tigers
let's head you know types so you like oh
alright I'm being told there are no
Tigers but whatever we're still gonna
bring you the EA play you know in love
huge surprises big announcements
incredible reveals and never-before-seen
gameplay coming up over the next hour
we've got game reveals galore world
premiere trailers of new titles some old
favorites making a comeback a look at a
new way Star Wars fans can live out
their greatest fantasies this year plus
a sneak peek at the future oh and pay
close attention because today you could
win one of thousands of steam codes for
more than a dozen great EA games on
Steam throughout the show keep an eye
out for discreetly placed golden letters
write them down as they appear and at
the end of the show will tell you where
you can enter that secret code for a
chance to win free games on Steam so
don't go anywhere
Who am I kidding none of us can leave
our houses but enough talking let's see
some games up first we're headed to the
Outlands that's right it's apex legends
time
[Music]
you should smile
hey apex fans the battle just keeps
getting bigger thanks to you
apex legends is coming off its most
successful most epic season yet and
we're just getting started
season 4 saw more of you jumping into
the fight than ever before and you've
kept that amazing momentum going forward
making season 5 the biggest and best
start to a season ever hold on to your
Holograms we hope you've been enjoying
season 5 fortunes favor which has seen
the introduction of our latest legend
lobha a major map change to Kings Canyon
rest in peace' skull town an all-new
ranked series and a ton of quality of
life updates but it's about to get even
better today I'm here to tell you about
what's coming next - season 5 with our
latest collection event lost treasures
take a look
adventurous Raiders explorers they risk
everything in such a fame fortune and
answers if you find what they're looking
for but if they survive they might walk
away with lost treasures
I'll high-five you all when I see you
mobile respawn
register Thanks
guns please guns I don't need guns I
know what I'm looking for I won't walk
away without it
Donna Jessica
as you just saw the lost treasures
collection event brings with it a ton of
great content including a new limited
time mode armed and dangerous' evolved
it's the return of a fan-favorite
snipers and shot he's only but with a
twist
sending out my decoy all armor is evil
armor and we're removing all of the
respawn beacons across the entire map
don't worry though you'll still be able
to bring back your teammates with the
help of a new item the mobile respawn
Deacon you'll have one of these in your
inventory at the start of each match
giving you the power to choose win and
more importantly where you bring your
teammates back into the battle lost
treasures also introduces the new town
takeover cryptos map ring which gives
players a closer look at what motivates
this drone wielding hacker
and of course the lost treasures
collection delivers a bunch of exclusive
content you can earn by completing
challenges as well as all new event
exclusive cosmetic items and the
introduction of you boy mirages heirloom
which is fittingly a trophy of himself
excited to see you all on the ring don't
worry there's plenty of bees to go
around
crown and the best part is you don't
have to wait that long
lost treasures drops on Tuesday June
23rd and that's not all apex fans the
battle is expanding that's right this
fall we're bringing apex legends to
steam and I know you're hoping wondering
praying so before you ask yeah cross
play is coming to apex this fall it's
been one of the biggest requests we get
and we're thrilled to finally deliver it
to our fans what am I forgetting oh yeah
one last thing let's make it official
we're huge fans of Nintendo here at
respawn and we are incredibly excited to
be bringing apex legends to the switch
this fall and we'll share more details
in the months ahead so that means you'll
be able to squad up no matter where are
you and your friends prefer to play xbox
playstation switch or on the PC via
Origen and steam we're throwing out a
lifeline and healing the divide between
the platforms on behalf of the entire
apex team we want to thank our
incredible community your passion for
the game is truly inspiring we look
forward to seeing you all in the arena
and don't forget check out lost
treasures on June 23rd
oh man how is it made I think a fiber
but hyperbola
I think I'm hiper been a really good
time here so school everyone one thing I
admire about apex Legends is its
commitment to having such a diverse
range of characters at the Sims we've
always believed representation and
diversity in games is critically
important perhaps now more than ever
it's difficult to put into words just
how meaningful it can be to see yourself
reflected in the games you play so here
to tell you in their own words are a few
members of our Sims community it's a
very interesting thing to explain it
feels empowering actually and very
moving it really taught me alive the
importance of just like keeping
relationships good with people it's
probably like the only place where I was
open they get to see my personality
first before seeing my disability I
guess you could say I found myself to be
the only black child in my school I was
discriminated I was bullied my skin tone
my height and my teeth first realized
that I was trans and I had I was like
praying to God to undo it I have this
world where I can express myself and be
myself where I come from Who I am the
color my skin you know who I'm attracted
to let any of that get in the way it was
it was no barriers no matter where I was
or what I was going through I had my
safe place this is plausible this is a
future you can have was almost like I
was peeking into the future and I didn't
know it at the time but it gave me hope
it gave me a sense of hope that I could
build a life that looked like
The Sims is almost like a utopia of what
I hope our world eventually becomes as I
got more comfortable with my character
in the game I got more comfortable with
myself I played a build meeting I play
to express myself I play to make a
difference a play to feel good about
myself I play to have confidence to have
fuel my creativity it's more than just a
game it's creating your life
as you just saw there are so many
reasons why I am proud to be part of the
Sims global community we want the Sims
to be a place of unity and hope a place
where you can be your authentic self and
build your vision for our shared world a
place to imagine what's possible to our
simmers thank you for everything you've
done to make your communities virtual
and real a better place
now I know some of you tuned in hoping
for some Sims news and we'll have plenty
to share as the summer goes on but we do
have one announcement for you we'll be
welcoming players on a whole new
platform as the sims 4 arrives on Steam
today take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everyone Alex here from the social team
and joining me today from our community
team is Freeman hey folks yes we're here
to tell you that it's not just the Sims
for arriving on Steam today five more
great EA games including titanfall 2 a
way out and dead space free all playable
right this second and when EA access
arrives on Steam this fall you can get
all those great titles and a ton more
with your membership you can also expect
to see our new releases on Steam - one
of the first arrive just a short while
ago with full mod support via Steamworks
the critics love it and we know you will
- this is command & Conquer remastered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back commander and steam isn't
the only platform getting some love
we'll be bringing games to more
platforms than ever you can expect seven
new games coming to switch in the next
12 months including burnout paradise
coming tomorrow and apex legends later
this year and we're bringing cross-play
to many of your favorite games -
starting with Need for Speed Heat and
continuing with some new titles being
revealed later in the show it's all
about giving you the freedom to play
what you want where you want and with
who you want it's about playing together
absolutely
now let's reveal some more games over to
you Greg quick reminder to keep an eye
out for those special golden letters
hidden throughout the show they could
appear anywhere and I mean anywhere so
keep your eyes open
write the letters down as they appear
and once you've got the full code you'll
be able to enter for a chance to win one
of more than a dozen great games on
Steam so stay tuned and find out where
to enter the code at the end of the show
now if you follow my content at all then
you know there's nothing I love more
than buffalo wings and discovering
inventive new games well I don't have
any buffalo wings but I do have
something just as tasty over the past
couple of years
EA is partnered with the amazing Studios
like haze light and joint to give us
such creative titles as a way out in
faith here to explain how they do it are
a few of the talented developers working
on the next wave of EA originals
sometimes you just have this great idea
off the game but it can be really hard
to do it on your own we wanted space for
our Studios crates they would even flow
free so that we can try unconventional
approaches to solving new ideas there
are times where you've gotta like break
past your own sort of mental blocks even
if that meant building a whole new kind
of game engine we get to do the game we
want to do nothing and I mean nothing
comes into the game if it doesn't follow
the vision we can really push our ideas
further and bigger than we first
imagined let's find that magic
[Music]
and now for a deeper dive into what
these developers are working on we turn
our spotlight on three studios a first
is haze light in their mild mannered
quiet leader Joseph Faris let's do it
please welcome Joseph Farah there are
like passionate people they're crazy
people there's me
[Music]
okay can you swear here oscar's you know
[Applause]
not polish is there a yeah I know I'm
coffee I can't help it man I was born in
Beirut 1977
I lived there 10 years of a civil war
and there was a lot of bad stuff
happening there we tried to move five
times to Sweden the fifth time they let
us in and that's like if you're Sweden
because I've given Sweden a lot to know
my third movies those are is basically
about my life when I came Sweden when I
was young I've done my patient movies
now have done three games and it's way
hard to make a game it's almost like the
audience have controlled of the pacing
on the story while the movies is being
paced for you
NVIDIA against there's so much to be
explored from a storytelling perspective
because of the interactivity there are
some students out there that are making
into have good stories but they pretty
much have one mechanic like you reuse
all the time the designers and the story
writers are kind of like doing two
different games that's why I founded his
life to keep pushing the boundaries but
it's possible in games
that's what game number three from his
life is all about the new game it takes
two is a co-op action adventure
platformer that would blow your mind
away the story starts out with a small
family Cody may that's the parents and
then Bros the little daughters so Cody
may about separate Rose doesn't want to
be divorced two secrets to dogs at a
wood and clay and these dogs magically
come alive and actually controls both
Cody and May and you could say you're
almost controlling their emotions you're
always playing in their emotions
there's even levels where we're actually
making a mechanic for their emotions so
again marrying the story and the
mechanics and I think for the players
that's gonna feel very new different and
unique they haven't played anything like
this before it takes two is that crazy
roller coaster ride that doesn't really
have an enemy it has an ending but that
endings that the roller coaster crashes
and you fly into the sky and get up into
space and when you're in space you like
what am i doing up here and then maybe
you get back to to earth again it's not
the best way to describe that it takes
to actually
Wow that would that was the best way to
describe it all right Joseph we love you
so much thank you keep it up over there
the Oscars of course ladies and
gentlemen let's keep this originals
train rolling and let's stay in Sweden
course I'm a fan of both their delicious
red gummy fish and their video games so
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Klaus and Olaf from joint games thanks
Greg
welcome to Gothenburg and will my home
unfortunately I didn't bring you any
Swedish fish but we do have some
exciting news for you about our latest
game at sewing
we've always been driven by love of rich
visual storytelling and creating strange
worlds that people can escape to the
weirder the better and I think my friend
Olaf would agree yeah absolutely and for
our next game though we wanted to try
something a little darker something out
of a gothic fairy tale but started with
a mood and some paintings screw into
this eerie strange world that feels like
something out of a beautiful twisted
dream and that's the world of random
lost and random is the story of even a
little girl with a big heart and an even
bigger temper after a horrible event the
changes of life she embarks on a
dangerous journey through the world
random
but fortunately she's not alone just
like I have holo
even also has a crazy little weird
friend thing with her along her journey
even discovers dicey a playful loyal
almost puppy like dice companion that
gives her the power to really change
things in the kingdom of random
despite the name an even swirled
randomness is feared and the dark force
controls every aspect of life from where
you live to how you act or what your
favorite color is it's a coming-of-age
story set against the backdrop of a
mysterious world but it holds a modern
message that's really relevant to our
world right now I think we can all
relate to the desire to try and control
the chaos around us with Dicey's help
though human learns the power and doing
just the opposite embrace the randomness
accept uncertainties in life and you'll
be surprised how far it takes you
imagine if you could change the course
of life with a roll of a dice what would
you do play it safe or trust in yourself
and take a chance we can't wait for you
to play and find out we're still a long
ways from launch but we hope you will
join even and dicey on the journey next
year until then please enjoy this first
look at lost and random will come to
random
the world of random bends with the role
of one guys and I said is rule this
kingdom for generations transforming the
fates of people just not you but what if
I told you there is another dice with
the power to change everything now my
friend it's your turn to rule to play
the odds and break the curse of random
[Music]
you can't have the sweet without the
sour
I know dicey they should be scared of us
right
[Music]
really cool that's a look at lost in
random in man embracing randomness I
feel like I live that every day of my
life you know I was gonna do that you
didn't know that
die seize my spirit animal the game's
out next year but for something that's
blasting off a whole lot sooner
take it away Kevin Franklin
a final strike games our team of
experienced industry veterans have
worked on incredible multiplayer
franchises we are passionately focused
on making great multiplayer games that's
why I am incredibly excited to announce
that we have partnered with the talented
team at EA to release our first ever
title rocket arena as you'll see we stay
loyal to the name of the game
it's a rockets only shooter that allows
players to get into the action quickly
and stay in the fight we want a rocket
Iranian to be an awesome competitive
experience to play with friends I think
you're gonna love what we've got in
store for you here is the all-new
trailer of rocket arena enjoy rockets
away
[Music]
have you ever wondered why life is so
good on crater sure we've got the
beautiful beaches quality public
transportation and exotic destinations
the people are courteous and friendly
always happy to help their fellowship
but the real reason life is so good
[Music]
let's hit the trail
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
turn your back on the water
[Music]
I'm here to rocket
[Music]
whoa freedom
so as you just saw rockets are obviously
awesome to blast all over the place but
in order to come out on top there's a
lot to master you'll have a range of
rocket-powered abilities to blast
opponents out of the arena and an
arsenal of evasive moves rocket jump
rocket climb and dodge to avoid getting
knocked out yourself
don't worry though you're never out of
the action for long even when you're out
you'll fly right back into the fray
you'll also be able to really customize
your own unique look and play style each
of the 10 year is available at launch
have their own rocket-powered abilities
and as you play you'll discover items
that allow you to further refine each of
your heroes play styles Plus every
character has a hundred levels of
progression that unlock new cosmetics
and rewards all that and much more when
rocket arena arrives on July 14th and
there's plenty more content to come in
our first season which begins just two
weeks after launch on July 28th and
brings with it a blast pass and a ton of
free content including new maps in game
events and a new playable character
rocket arena is a game meant to be
played with friends regardless of
platform that's why we're thrilled to
announce cross play support right from
the start
so grab your friends regardless of their
platform and get ready to blast off with
rocket arena on July 14th on PlayStation
Xbox origin and steam and we'll be
sharing more gameplay right after the
show with the help of some great content
creators so check us out on youtube at
the link below see you in the arena wow
that looks great and hopefully you've
all been keeping track of the golden
letters hidden throughout the show and
nearly crack the code here's a hint
it's not Kanye keep an eye out for the
last couple of letters and then at the
end of the show we'll reveal where you
need to go to enter the code at a chance
to win some great games on Steam now
from the future of rocket warfare we
head to a different kind of battle it's
the real reason I didn't get any sleep
last night
and if you thought you heard sleigh
bells that's because it might as well be
Christmas in June it's finally time to
talk Star Wars
squadrons ok I promise you we are gonna
get a first look at some brand new
gameplay in just a moment but first for
anyone who doesn't fully grasp why I'm
so excited
earlier this week EAM Lucasfilm dropped
a trailer that literally gave me all the
fields chills joy excitement and then
more chills on top of that take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
use that moment
when the perfect shot
makes history
five pilots one squadron the galaxy's
finest
[Music]
Wow the eight-year-old and all of us is
celebrating and excited the 37 year old
man on this couch is excited ladies and
gentlemen for the second year in a row I
have the honor and privilege of helping
introduce a new Star Wars title and here
to put the hype in hyperdrive is none
other than motives creative director Ian
Frazer hello Ian hey Greg how you doing
I'm great how are you doing good happy
to actually get to show this to people I
bet now in my copious notes I have on
you I'm told you are quite the star wars
fan have been a long time how long have
you liked Star Wars I've been the star
wars fan for pretty much my whole life I
don't even remember the first time I saw
the movies and as a kid there was a lot
of different parts of Star Wars I loved
one of them was being a pilot that idea
of climbing into an x-wing or a TIE
fighter so you know I played all the
flight games in the 90s and I got pretty
obsessive about them I'd pause
meticulously draw the insides of the
cockpits and stuff and actually I dug up
some of those drawings for my parents
attic over the holidays we're showing
them right now to the world this strikes
me is above and beyond the normal level
of Star Wars fandom I think it motive
you find that quite a few people have
that level of Star Wars fandom we
started this project I talked to a lot
of people as they joined the team and a
lot of them had similar kinds of stories
of things they'd done as kids one of
them even built a functional cockpit in
his garage
that's FanDuel how do you guys go from
being a fan drawing what you see in the
game we're building a cockpit in your
garage it's actually making this game
well I think that fandom just love of
Star Wars has provided a really good
foundation for us but on top of that of
course the team at mode have got a lot
of experience working with Star Wars
when they worked on Battlefront 2 and
when battlefront too wrapped up there
was a really small group of us that were
really into particularly the pilot
experiences in Star Wars and we wanted
to make something new something that
really went all in on that part of the
fantasy and so we we did kind of a
grassroots initiative our started a
little passion project and that ramped
up into eventually what is the game
we're going to show you today you talk
about you know your passion for this
your nostalgia for Star Wars flight
games of the past how do you honor that
but make something brand new it's been
interesting you know we're trying
kind of pull from that spiritual
heritage of many different games in that
time period at the same time we want to
do something that feels fresh and new
for fans today and so we've tried to
look at is sort of the spiritual core of
what I think are the best of the Star
Wars flight games of the past and what
they did that I love is that they made
that part of the universe real a level
of depth and detail that they show in
the ships of the way that you control
them is something that I remember fondly
from my childhood and it's something
that we're trying to do very much with
squadrons you know in real life being a
pilot is hard it takes skill and that's
something that you'll see throughout the
game you know as you start off playing
it's pretty straightforward fly around
shoot your lasers but as you get deeper
into it you start learning how to divert
energy from your lasers to your to your
engines how to shift your shields from
the front to the back to cover your butt
in a dogfight or at the higher levels of
skill you could do really crazy stuff
like you can boost your engines fly
ahead cut them off whip around 180 and
shoot a missile off your own tail while
drifting backwards like real ace pilot
stuff and that's that's really where we
have a lot of fun with the game I want
to do that I want to learn too that I
understand the nuts and bolts of how to
play it is there a single-player story
is there a multiplayer mode what are we
getting into it's actually some of both
so the game starts with a brand new
single-player story takes place a little
bit after Return of the Jedi and it has
kind of a unique dual perspective
approach to it so when the game starts
you're going to create two pilots you
create a new Republic pilot and an
imperial pilot and you're gonna
alternate between their perspectives
mission to mission over the course of
the story you're gonna meet a diverse
cast of characters along the way and
also a few familiar faces now when
you're done with that story and you've
played maybe a bit in the practice rage
you say hey I want to try multiplayer we
want to make it really easy for you to
hop online with your friends and play
competitive space battles at that point
and so we've done a lot to try to reduce
the barriers to make it as easy as
possible for you to play with your
friends and so I'm happy to say we fully
support cross play you could be on ps4
Xbox one PC you could be playing on a
traditional display or in VR which fun
fact the entire game supports VR from
beginning to end pretty cool but
regardless of how you're playing which
platform they can all play together just
hook up with your friend connect have an
awesome space pal you just discard my
mind man like I don't that's
awesome that is the big question when
can people actually play it ah not too
long actually start where squadrons is
coming out on October 2nd okay okay not
too long at all I was worried about you
I thought you leave me on a teaser there
you didn't actually deliver it I
appreciate that
the next big ask I have on behalf of
everybody watching I'm sure who came
here for one specific reason can we see
some new gameplay of it can we see any
gameplay of it absolutely I kind of
figured you might want to on behalf of
everyone at motive and the team at
Lucasfilm I am very happy to show you
the world's first look at gameplay of
Star Wars squadrons enjoy
[Music]
second Death Star's call with the
imperial fleet is still a threat
Vanguard squadron let's make history
is it titled quadrant everything we've
done has led to this finish those bad
guards stop this is Star Wars squadron
earn your wings in a single-player story
spanning two factions all stations and
master multiplayer battles as a squadron
of five
with the option to play the entire game
in VR this is the definitive Star Wars
pilot experience
[Music]
you'll begin your career in a
single-player story
welcome to titan squadron where you'll
play as two combat pilots flying for
both the Empire and the New Republic
you'll experience this world through
your cockpit the instrumentation in
grenadine provides critical feedback
about power management targeting and
shields with a squadron of diverse
characters at your side prove your
skills on increasingly challenging
missions
Vanguard
welcome to the nadir Dockyard one of my
spies has linked the attacks with the
New Republic Starhawk project the story
of the two pilots you playing stick
together will shape the balance of power
in the galaxy to take the fight online
you'll need flight time with all eight
ship's fighters are the most flexible
and versatile able to handle any
situation interceptors are fast and
highly maneuverable let's get a ideal
for hunting down your opponent's star
fighters support ships can keep allies
safe and stocked up as well as
disrupting enemy fighters farmers are
the heavy hitters able to deal
devastating damage
enemy flag ships and star fighters if
you've got a preferred component you
need something customized I'll take care
of you unlock everything you need to
customize your pilot and star fighters
simply by playing the game from
cosmetics to an arsenal of over fifty
components that alter how your ships fly
fight and survive
I'll deal with it you can dramatically
change your loadout depending on your
squadron strategy
finally got up this will be critical in
star wars squadrons multiplayer modes
first up dogfights this is an all-out
5v5 battery
fine tune your loadouts
to work as a team moving in on the enemy
utilize components like tractor beams
turrets and like mines just slow down
your opponent's or set up your squad
mates for the kill
four teams looking for an even greater
challenge it's time to prove yourself in
Star Wars squadrons signature mode fleet
battles fleet battles are multistage
conflicts whether playing solos or with
friends options you compete against
other players or AI as a squadron of
five don't worry I got imported meat
your team in the social hub to solidify
a strategy coordinate loadouts and
prepare for takeoff first push the
frontline by winning the dogfight in the
center of the map next attack or defend
to medium sized capital ships
we've lost our capital ship and finally
the ultimate goal target and destroy the
subsystems of your opponent's massive
black ship and take it down at each
phase your squadron either pushes the
line forward or falls back to defend
keep our flagship safe
it's your squadrons choice of how to
play stay together strike quickly
stealth and subversion we need to hurry
a unified squadron is the key to victory
ow
this is star wars squadrons join the
galaxy's finest and make your margin
you other hope this galaxy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
just me and to keep it your hardest like
[Music]
scored a goal
and your hero a history cough your name
[Applause]
is something 60,000 people so city bonds
football my heart feel it in comes see
unknown I want the real thing I want not
sweat with him since little hair Rosie
[Music]
[Applause]
I want to live in the floods
I want to feel it all now that's a lot
to look forward to but there's more here
to tell us about the future of gaming is
EA's chief studio officer
Laura Miele thanks grey and thanks Lamar
welcome to the EA sports family there
are great things to come from EA Sports
for all of you and that's just the
beginning
as you've seen throughout the show today
our electronic artists are working hard
to bring you more of the games that you
want to play games like Star Wars
squadrons apex legends and command &
Conquer these games all exist because of
you your voices are heard and we are
acting on your feedback now we've talked
a lot about all the exciting games
you'll be playing this year but our
studios are working even further out
creating new experiences new stories new
gameplay all enabled by new console
technology and we're so excited that was
to come we don't want to wait until next
June to share what the teams are working
on
generation shifts are an opportunity to
push beyond the boundaries of gaming as
we know it today and this time is no
different our studios are taking their
crazy ambitious ideas and making them
real criterion is known for how their
games feel from superior physics to
nuanced details of gameplay this team
hand curates the moment-to-moment
experience and with the new consoles
this year there will be a seamless
immersion which will get you into the
race in a matter of seconds Bioware
imagines and creates worlds where you
become the hero of your own story and
we're using this next generation of
technology to make those fantasy worlds
your reality for every console
generation dice sets the bar for
excellence in audio and visual
presentation we are creating epic
battles at a scale and fidelity unlike
anything you've experienced before
that motive we are working on a highly
ambitious and innovative new game that
puts the power and creativity in your
hands and it's the experience that would
have been impossible without next gen
technology this is just the beginning of
the things we are working on and there
is so much more to come the future of EA
Studios is not just about new technology
it's about you your voices your ideas we
want to be where you come to play we
want to make games for everyone so
please keep giving us your feedback and
let's build the future together
on behalf of all of our studios thank
you for joining us today but before we
sign off there's just one more game we
would love to share cousin Darren over
to you thank you so the moment is here
we finally get to say we're back we're
doing it skates happening we're rolling
we've secretly got together
it's the beginning the skate evolution
continues we've been waiting years
honestly to to make the right game at
the right time with the right idea and
really really pleased to say that we're
here it is really early but it takes a
little while to find guys or wake them
up
dude cars still we've got a long way to
go but we're stoked and this is just the
beginning and seriously we really can't
wait to bring you guys in and have you
be a part of it with us we want to thank
you for your passion your patience and
all the support that you've shown you
know us to get to this point the
comments it's it's amazing we cannot
believe you commented this into
existence amazing skate changed my life
thank you so much
skate forever guys guys we did it we
brought back skate thank you to EA thank
you to cuz Thank You to Darren thank you
to you thank you to me I can't believe
that I'm so happy in my heart rate is
this what exercise feels like ladies and
gentlemen I can't believe it before we
go because I love you guys here are the
last letters of the secret code if you
think you've got the complete code go to
play or not GG / EA and enter for a
chance to win one of thousands of free
games sponsored by player GG you can
find the official rules and everything
else over at player GG / e a now this
has been in an amazing experience an
amazing opportunity for all of us all
over the world to come together and
celebrate gaming thank you for being
part of EA play until next time I'll see
you online and it's been my pleasure to
serve you
[Music]
every girl
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]